some breaking news now the world's
largest oil producers have agreed to the
biggest ever cut in oil production
demand for oil has plummeted amid the
coronavirus crisis and with it the price
per barrel in response OPEC Russia and
oil other oil-producing nations have
made a deal to reduce production by
around 10 million barrels a day in May
and June our economics editor Abbot Ali
joins us now live via Skype from London
a bit they had to do this it's in their
own self-interest to do so the kind of
shot themselves in the foot really
happened they need to do something but
the pressure really came from the United
States which wants to see a cutting
production and cutting production
between 10 to 15 million barrels a day
why because the shale industry in the
United States is under under threat
there is there could be up to about 70
odd companies that could fail because
oil prices have dropped to $20 a barrel
currently we're at about $3 a barrel but
that still isn't good enough for the
shale producers they need shell a shell
they need prices at between the 40 to
$50 a barrel there are 10 million jobs
associated with the shale industry in
the United States and that's a huge
constituency for president Trump present
Trump doesn't need any more job losses
in the last three weeks alone we've seen
17 millions jobs lost because of the
pandemic so there really needs to be a
bottom to this now the United Saudi
Arabia and Russia could have sustained a
price war for another two three years
maybe you know because they have huge
wealth which they have stored away in
their cut in the in their foreign
currency reserves and so they could have
sustained this but the pressure was
coming from other OPEC members as well
you've got to think of places like
Nigeria Nigeria had set a budget for $59
a barrel and so they have just turned to
the IMF and the World Bank and requested
7 billion dollars to see them through
these pandemic so he's getting really
crucial but those other
in a similar position as well our
business editor a Batali reporting live
there from London many thanks indeed a
bit